uh
[Applause]
[Music]
hi i'm melvin nice to meet you guys how
are you
this is terrifying i'm not gonna lie to
you
thank you thank you
okay so it's not a design no that's the
actual teddy on the sweater no is it
yeah he moved that [ __ ] bro
that's
okay
it is a secret
[Laughter]
meet the guy in the street see him then
see the teddy bear and go
mental health i wouldn't do that no but
there's a temptation no that's just he's
having fun
you know no
no some people will never stop wetting
the bed is it's a thing we'll name him
today he hasn't been named yet
[Music]
he got don't remember
melvin you remember no
he took a big album
he rest in peace
a lot of these young folks watching
who's big l
a lot of the old people like we
appreciate you
now ladies if you
[Music]
okay who's popping the drinks
guys i'm 19. so you can't have two okay
no no it's [ __ ] buddha head
buddha head's back
yeah little girl who's happening on the
date with the asian mom
who are you ready to date
who
[Laughter]
she's there that's her right there
dude where's my car molly but does
anyone want cider i'm like the bartender
today one two three what's your favorite
thing about yourself oh that's the first
okay oh she's the first of course shout
out to her she's a teacher's pet shout
out to her she's forward hey i'm in the
back of the line but i'm in the back of
the line but [ __ ] gonna know me
so yeah
what's up with you i like that i like
your sweater yay what do you do for a
living yeah yeah i know all these red
pill dudes be complaining about that
masculine no no go ahead but that's not
masculine that's
masculine
i mean that's what they would say me
percy i like it go before girlfriend you
like masculine energy pus don't even do
that
don't let me do that don't even do that
i'm trying to pick up a woman for doing
her thing i just and you want to ruin it
i can't ask a question no just let let
us enjoy this ask the questions let us
let us enjoy this heteronormative
experience i just asked this question
i can't ask a question
know i didn't realize what i was talking
to this woman and she brought up like
the whole train stuff right and then and
then and then i'm like well you as a sis
she's like don't say cis don't i'm not
no [ __ ] sis nothing i ain't no
[ __ ] [ __ ] wow
women hate the term cis women
okay sis
they're stupid
we've established that a long time
we've established that
a long assault ago calling me stupid
like they don't know
they know
they know
[Laughter]
i feel like i can tell like pretty good
dad jokes but what do you what do you
call a cow with three legs tri-tip
would you what
call a cow with three legs tri-tip
i don't know
cheers cheers cheers do you guys like
movies
yes yes what's your favorite movie top
three as a kid my favorite movie was
forest gump just because it was really
light it's really fun you know what
that's a viet girl
i don't know what i remember i remember
this is what i did this that's the viet
girl who once she met and the one mom
went
[Music]
yeah yeah and that girl the curly hair
right there
at the end she's a backup singer
she says yeah
like she goes shoe up just to make sure
that
[Music]
what's your favorite movie top three
that's what he did i like that i like
the energy do you like marvel i do
okay
wait who's your favorite superhero
spider-man okay classic spider-man
spider-man though andrew garfield i'm
sorry what about the spider-man who
kissed the [ __ ] upside down
i feel like i feel like louis city like
spider-man
i feel like
i feel like
[Music]
what about the spiderman that keeps your
[ __ ] upside down
i don't know when women tell me they
like spiderman i think they just like
that scene yes that's what i feel like
yeah that's what i feel i could be wrong
me too
no that movie was like made for like the
female games so i'm so happy
shut the [ __ ] up
let her live her life man i want to
support her i love that [ __ ] yeah
shoot up you know in the uk being a
backup dancer as an insult
yeah
yeah yeah in the uk they got a whole
song about like
you're just a backup
backup dance really i gotta listen to
that [ __ ] who sings that [ __ ] i think
it's stormzy are you currently like
studying anything yeah i'm studying uh
i'm majoring in pr at why does guy look
like rice gum's little brother who rice
gum
that's how you know this [ __ ]
doesn't watch youtube let's keep going
who rise gum did you call them rice gum
that's right that's an asian youtuber's
name
have you been in any relationships i
have i have how long how were they
about a year why did it end good
[Music]
yeah so something just happened i think
i saw something that i shouldn't have
seen
so like through the phone type through
the phone on instagram
[Music]
too oh i saw it on my phone
yeah
wait wait wait what's your sign what's
your size oh
no why
why we just get to the good part because
i wanted to know what he saw through the
phone
that she you cut the [ __ ] you cut the
you you cut you cut the juice
you cut the juice okay listen you cut
the juice i just don't got the energy
i'm not gonna lie every time i hear what
i cut the juice i just died a little bit
inside he was about to go we didn't
understand what the [ __ ] went on my
sperm cell count just drops every time i
i just i can't the anger i used to feel
when i used to hear i i just don't got
it i'm sorry guys so i'll let you guys
get in the comments and talk [ __ ] about
astrology do it do it for me because i i
can't fight this fight any longer oh
like a zebra oh okay you're libra yeah
me too
yo how many libras are there here oh my
god wait okay so do you have like a hot
take okay i'm gonna need like a subject
though
like i don't have music when i first
listened to him i i didn't get the hype
about frank ocean
does this [ __ ] even talk no because i
just seen her make faces this whole time
maybe it's the editing i just
who am i thinking of when i do that
who you think about
the back of your head look ridiculous
you remember that from man tv okay your
head look ridiculous
i like my shoe off girl better i'm from
the bay originally yeah see that's a red
flag now she's good
you know why it's a red flag
because she likes to go dum dum dum dum
dum jesus christ had dreads so shake him
i ain't got none but i'm planning on
growing some imagine all the hebrews
went dumb there's some type of cherries
i don't care nobody says e40's voice is
one of the dumbest voices in hip-hop
tell them where to go tell them what i
got
ghost ride the whip
[Music]
uh jerry you don't seem interested
don't hit me with a basketball
that's my personality yeah i'm not it's
the age
but he's
cute there's some people that are like
pretty long distance from him so that
might be like uh
maybe yeah maybe
you know there's a people that long
distance so maybe you should shoo up the
[ __ ] out of here
listen listen you know what i like about
glasses i know if i stuck her in a
battle royale she had to kill everybody
to get the prize she would do it without
hesitating because it's just a logical
course of action
i like your sweater so i'm gonna say i
like your sweater i like that kind of
person yeah shout out to her yeah but
she's not
it's not aggressive
but it is stern geez
[Music]
good good good are you nervous at all
extremely me too i'm a little bit
nervous
i do community college but i'm a
business major right now yeah business
are you planning on transferring like
yes not exactly sure where yet but
consider usc consider usc transfer
you'll show me the spots
i say [ __ ] i can't say [ __ ] i ain't
saying [ __ ]
i think i think he's definitely feeling
that one yeah if i had to guess i think
you're picking the redhead one yeah i go
to ucla remember we're rivals
i know a bit of a red flag but distance
wouldn't be a problem for us i'm gonna
tell you a secret ucla was my dream
school too oh really what would you say
is like a green flag a green flag okay
this is like a really specific green
flag but like if they can cook like
that's a plus you know
it's okay you don't need to know how to
do it okay
you can make like very basic things like
a salmon bowl i got you oh
you stupid you're really tough
yeah you're really really really dumb
i was about to say i really like your
outfit those boots are awesome thank you
i was scared to wear them because i
didn't know how tall you were kind of a
power move where'd you get the screen
this skirt is from d-pop shop
second-hand i'm super into fashion i saw
your little bear you'd love to name it
what do you have any ideas honestly i
feel like melvin jr was a good one okay
style is fun and like you can tell a lot
about a person looking at their outfit
what would you like to say about me you
like black
[Laughter]
i mean if i was going to be generous and
i was going to kind of get into my libra
mode i would probably say that the fact
that you have a teddy bear on your chest
means that you don't want to take
yourself too seriously you like being a
little bit silly you can get in touch
with your child in her child so that's
kind of cute and i don't know i like a
sensitive man yeah
pretty good
pretty good actually i hated myself the
whole process
okay the black is giving like a little
bit reserved mysterious but then the
teddy bear is like okay well he has a
soft spot
oh
[Music]
on
one on one so i say like i don't i don't
talk about i i know this first hand on
one my dude
there's two sides to everybody you know
what i've been trying to get recently
but [ __ ] throwback yeah
i want a racing jacket really bad but i
haven't been able to like find one we
got a fifth we'll find one we'll find
one so are you into fashion or anything
like that not really are you
i swear whatever looks not actually
no
[ __ ] that right i think we already know
who's gonna win growing up i liked a lot
of anime are you like are you still into
anime here i honestly don't have time
but i read a lot of manga and i'm
watching spy family right now we should
watch one together yeah never gonna
happen never ever gonna happen not this
time never gonna happen never gonna
happen never gonna happen never gonna
happen never gonna happen never gonna
happen never gonna happen
brother would never put me on one of
these shows miss tell me yeah we should
do i'm like nah
nah nah i'm not interested
i know they're supposed to choose for me
but i want you to know that's never
gonna happen even if they choose us to
go on a date it's still never going to
happen motherfucker's going to be listen
i don't give a [ __ ] next round
eliminate yourself yes
write your own name listen listen we're
going to play this game correctly um i
want to ask what's your
okay nationality i'm chinese but um
outbourne like here in l.a my mom's from
china and like my dad kind of grew up in
hong kong so nice
i'm bosnian but i grew up here yeah just
both of my parents are from there i'm
estonian white
did she say bosnian
let me play it back i think she said
bostonian i'm bosnian but i grew up here
yeah she's both of my parents are from
there she's sebastian
and i got to show love to my ex
yugoslavian people hold on hold on
the the caption says said bostonian but
what she said
i'm bosnian so you know sorry for what i
said earlier you're white yeah
i'm not gonna lie
bosnia's move different yeah
they got their own mafia yeah yeah yeah
i wouldn't [ __ ] with that so there's
serbs and bosnians bosnians are
traditionally muslim yeah they have a
small minority christian serbs not as
many muslims and so there's like a
religious divide between the two
countries
they beef in
all the time i really like it they're
actually lived there for like a year oh
wow how'd you like that experience it
was so good i feel like it's always nice
to like meet people that are the same
like you and just like really get in
touch with your culture do you know
exactly what you're like looking for
like long term short term just for fun
honestly i'm still trying to figure that
out to be honest
um i've only like been on this earth for
19 years so there's a lot for me to like
figure out thank you
are you involved in anything on campus
yeah so i'm um a campus ambassador and
then i'm also on a dance team you're
gonna like bust out a movie oh my gosh
no
it would be crazy if you didn't feel
like
if you do if you do i'll drink
wait okay i'll jerk and then you jerk
i'll take that i'll take that one
that's pretty good that's pretty good
sounds good is it my turn
wait that was really good thank you
my toss
i'm sorry i didn't deserve it either no
yeah so we could dance together a lot
okay uh rapid fire
uh
so the weather yeah it's it's okay yeah
what what what
what just happened there he's supposed
to ask her questions but he's really not
interested
yeah and he decided let's just dab in
the middle let's skip ahead
okay two
three
are you surprised
did you what were you expecting that or
was it close calls i was kind of hoping
for it you were i'm glad to hear that
thank you guys you just did really good
thank you guys for getting out the
[ __ ] way so i get the biz i really
wanted
why does she got a yacht pose
uh i mean she got the scars she's doing
the whole thing i respect it who did he
pick he picked her up it's a top three
it's regina i think you picked brianna
on the first round too
that would have been awkward we can go
thrifting now we can and you gotta get
me into usc
on a name for the thanks
you get to name it since you won brianna
i'll go with that oh that's a good name
she named it after herself that flag is
as red as your hair
with the mat with the matching skirt
girl you know you dressed like a red
flag
i'm just saying you know before y'all
bang a little bit of possession this
don't sound so bad it's only after you
get in deep that you realize oh [ __ ]
this swamp is very smug
this swamp is muddy
and i ain't talking about butt stuff
moving on yes uh but yeah that's it for
this video it looks like they don't go
on a date so good for them
yeah cool
easy
peasy